all right so Adam Warlock is the newest
hero anti-hero uh misunderstood Baddie
turned goody to be introduced into the
MCU and who may just be one of our
Mainstay characters leading us into
Secret Wars in a few years and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down this character from his
Origins Powers big moments in the comics
along where he may be going in the
future of the MCU I know one place will
poulter's character will not be going
anywhere near a waterfall believe in
yourself the rest is up to me and don't
go Jason
potential minor spoilers for Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 just a heads up you
know so you're not mad if you watch this
but yeah I'm your host Jared now let's
get into I mean not into but let's talk
about Adam Warlock on the ground
so obviously Adam Warlock is the latest
character in the MCU teased all the way
back in the post-credits scene from
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 with the
Sovereign Queen teasing he is the next
step in their evolution
[Music]
I think I shall call him
Adam
harder better faster stronger he is
basically a Daft Punk song but this
latest potential MCU Hero has a rich
history in the old world of the comics
dating all the way back to 1967 where he
kinda sort of made a first Cameo
appearance in Fantastic Four issue 66
and 67 as him a genetically created
perfect specimen by a group of
scientists calling themselves The
Enclave now like any science experiment
these old dudes wanted to use him for
nefarious purposes but luckily him
sensed this damaging their facility and
getting the heck out of there him then
had a run-in with Thor after trying to
steal his gal pal lady Sif and was
promptly given a Smackdown by Odin's son
resulting in him returning to the safety
of his regenerative cocoon to heal now
at this point the character was revamped
a bit by editor-in-chief Roy Thomas and
Gil Kane making him into more of a
christ-like figure that we see here in
live action and no lie Thomas later
claimed in 2009 inspiration for the
change of this character came from the
wildly popular at the time just at the
time musical Jesus Christ Superstar
you not
changing his name to Adam Warlock Adam
like you know Adam and Eve and having
his second origin be tied to the high
evolutionary inserting the Soul Stone
into his old Noggin and sending him to
counter Earth a hopeful utopian Planet
very similar to Earth that the high
evolutionary was trying to you know
perfect however man Beast a failed
experiment of the high evolutionary was
running amok on this utopian Planet
which resulted in Adam Warlock or just
Adam or just warlock it depends on your
preference here becoming counter Earth's
first high-profile superhero trying to
rid the planet of the evil presence of
man Beast which eventually was achieved
by warlock after these Feats Adam
ventured into the cosmos where he came
across the Universal Church of scientist
not I mean truth truth The Universal
Church of Truth which was an
Intergalactic cult led by a nut job mad
man named Magnus the goal of this church
was to spread its teachings Across the
Universe Planet by planet and if the
planet was willing they would assimilate
their teachings into their culture and
boom good great grand that is it but if
they were not willing Magnus in the
church would essentially pull a ronin
the accuser and purify the planet
eliminating any and all who did not
submit now the Shocker is Magnus is
revealed to be a corrupted future
version of Adam Warlock because of the
prolonged use of the Soul Stone the old
I gotta defeat my future evil self
storyline so in order to defeat himself
Adam teamed up with Pip the troll Thanos
and his daughter Gamora to defeat Magnus
after doing so Adam then turns on Thanos
when the other five Infinity Stones are
discovered but is displaced in time
somehow defeated and his soul is
residing in in the Soul Stone after
Thanos took it from him in a last ditch
effort Adam's Soul projected from the
stone now a full on being of pure energy
defeated Thanos by turning him into
stone talk about Rock Bottom
Adam's Consciousness Retreats back to
his new home in the soul World which
exists in the Soul Stone the final bit
of Adam warlock's story follows that of
a very familiar story we've already seen
on the big screen The Infinity Gauntlet
Saga though a bit different here or
there the general framework of Thanos
who surprisingly found his way back to
life acquires all of the infinity gems
into his Gauntlet in order to court
death snapping his fingers and half the
population disappears blah blah blah you
get it you've seen it you know this but
Adam who's been living in the soul world
within the soul stone is resurrected
alongside Maura and teams up with
Earth's Heroes to defeat Thanos and take
back the stones however instead of them
being destroyed like in the MCU live
action we've seen this they are
otherwise split up amongst who are
coined to be the infinity watch this
comprised of Adam Warlock Gamora pip the
troll Drax Moondragon and secretly
don't Thanos that that last one threw me
for a loop but you know what Adam you do
whatever you gotta do obviously Adam my
boy has been through a lot and each
incarnation of the character seems to
have slightly different powers and
abilities with the most common being
superhuman speed durability stamina
strength agility the ability of flight
manipulation of cosmic energy into
Cosmic projectiles recuperation which is
essentially him reverting back into his
cocoon for regeneration like some sort
of caterpillar butterfly boy and
immortality solely pun intended on the
Soul Stone being a technicality that he
cannot die because death cannot claim
his soul like a Dark Souls boss he also
became stronger and stronger with every
Resurrection which later allowed him to
dive into Quantum magic quotes around
that on top of the cosmic Powers he
already possessed this allowed him to
tap into Quantum energy creating force
fields and teleport at the speed of
light creating wormholes and other
irregularities in space now the Soul
Stone also allowed for a transmuting
healing Factor essentially stealing the
essence from other living beings and
transferring that to himself or others
basically this dude has a stacked perk
tree of any and all powers out there
even being in the possession of the full
Infinity Gauntlet a time or two
obviously this MCU version is going to
be a bit different with things because
the Soul Stone isn't implanted into his
head so a lot of those powers are
morphed into different things in the
comics he also had a relationship with
the Guardians of the Galaxy even leading
them and that's where I think they will
be taking things with this character
moving forward nothing is officially
announced as of now but with Secret Wars
being on the horizon along with the
connections to the Fantastic Four I
believe that he'll play a prominent role
in at least at least Secret Wars and as
a soft reboot that secret Wars is
rumored to be rumor everyone I could see
him alongside rocket and maybe some of
the other new faces being the ragtag
group of the Guardians it really depends
what Kevin feige has up his sleeve and
how faithful they are looking to stick
to the source material but uh yeah that
is a a very rough Cliff Notes version of
this new face we are hopefully going to
see a few more times in the MCU moving
forward now I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the character do you want to
see more of this chiseled jawed man on
the big screen and what did you think of
will poulter's portrayal and I'll let
you know we're currently running in
competition giving away three copies of
Ant-Man quantumania the steel book on
the 15th of May and all you got to do to
get a chance of winning this is like
this video subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment down below with
your thoughts of Adam Warlock or even
Guardians volume 3. we picked comments
at random at the end of every single
month in the winners of last month are
on screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other cool
videos we have a post-credits scene and
full movie breakdown of the Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 go and watch that but
with all of that out of the way thank
you so much for your constant support
I've been Jared you've been you uh I'll
see in the next one take care and uh
peace